[Music]
you guys know richard branson is right
yeah yeah
virgin virgin man are you fans of
richard branson yeah i'm not about to
say something that'll make you not like
himself i don't know if he's the kind of
person he'd be a fan of is he does he
have music or anything well he owns a
lot of music
i like him
and i've read half his book which is
pretty good which one uh i forgot which
one but it was about his like maybe his
biography like maybe how he started i
think he uh used to sell magazines as a
kid and he started his record label and
all that is it called like a virgin
maybe maybe i read like the first
episode he's like a billionaire right
yeah yes he is a billionaire no i don't
follow him on those social media so i
guess i'm not that big of a fan i
enjoyed uh virgin flights when they're
all like partying and it was virgin
flights are tired it was all purple it
felt cool like damn this is a cool
drawer they let you uh do pranks over
the pa like if you ask them you're like
i want to pack my friend they were mad
fun and you had to they had that thing
where you could see a girl in another
seat and you can text them in to their
oh yeah you can send to 34.
and also in their own terminal in their
airline like when you walk into there
they're playing like wu-tang in the
it just felt way more like hip and young
all right so for those watching that
aren't familiar with him he's basically
this guy that owns this conglomerate the
virgin group and they just own
everything yeah i think right now people
that don't know who he is he's mostly
known for the billionaire that went to
the moon or not the moon but then space
yeah and dates hot models i don't know
if he still does i i just know that
right now he does a lot of parasailing
at the beach and he's like an extreme
extreme sports kind of dude or something
right every picture i see him he's
[ __ ] like wind sailing with the hot
chick behind him oh really yeah i don't
know why in my mind i just keep seeing
the jet ski photo with a girl in his bed
it's always like that
maybe that's a mandela he had a booboo
cell phone line though that virgin no
one's trying to be in that virgin virgin
mobile
that might be his grandkids because i
know he just
quarantines at the island with his
family and [ __ ] too he's like british
right yeah he's british he seemed like
what i'm doing in the speedo like
walking up and down the beach and not
feeling weird about it it's not feeling
right he's that grandpa with a speedo
looking at your trunks like you're a
little baby yeah when you got billions
you could do what the [ __ ] you want
what's wrong yeah man
well i follow his instagram right and i
feel like all he does is just dance
he's at like he's like he's like you see
like everyone else around him in suits
and i was just dancing and he's like
somewhere else dancing opening up a
hotel and dancing yeah if you put it
like that if you look at the like the
billionaire guys out there like whatever
he's gotta be one of the cooler ones
yeah i'm a fan yeah okay good i'm a fan
[ __ ] it i'm glad are you baiting us no
i'm actually not this is a good thing
that's why i say it's fine if you uh i
hate them man okay there you go i don't
like them either hey we don't like them
over here bro yeah i jump shipping all
the things that uh richard branson
stands for i didn't know that he had
such a passionate uh
he's got this like really big initiative
against the death penalty hmm oh i
didn't know that against it yeah he he
wants to just stop that's what we think
every country from having it like
eventually somehow
and i think it gets leveraged by uh
he'll cut he'll like cancel certain big
deals with countries if they like
they have it yeah just like it it
actually
matters a whole lot to him wow you're
really familiar with singapore oh yeah
what happens in singapore when uh
somebody brings a little uh drugs into
the uh and gets caught dude they [ __ ]
you up
they [ __ ] ruin you
don't they can you whoopsh um for drug
trafficking really it's it's mandatory
uh death penalty wow
[ __ ] i mean like what was trafficking
like were you brought in some weed
that's not trafficking no that's
trafficking a joint
may not
i really think if you have like even
just uh even like cocaine or something
like that they don't mess around
i heard there's a double standard though
in a lot of those countries where like
the rich and the royals and then the
they they all do drugs and they party
but then like the average citizens
they'll get in deep [ __ ] if they get
caught with it well it's cause you need
the examples yeah you need to so the uh
what happened here is that richard
branson is calling on singapore oh [ __ ]
to um to spare the life of a man who is
recently um
awaiting his execution
for drug trafficking yeah uh is a little
catch
this man is of such low mental capacity
that he was tricked into being a mule oh
that's he doesn't even know
why he's there fully understand that
he's gonna be killed whoa wow what do
you mean he doesn't fully understand so
they got someone that's like low iq or
someone that's kind of disabled
and took advantage of like a down
syndrome kid or something yeah so they
figured out that like this dude um they
did like a mental assessment on him
turns out he's got like an iq of like 69
and uh
he's not even like smart enough to
understand that that he's on death row
so they're like tomorrow we're going to
fame bay and he's like yeah
he thinks he's going to get let out
damn yeah so here's this guy's story his
name is
nagenthran darmilla
dharmalingam and uh
yeah he apparently some some drug people
got a hold of him they they had him be a
mule just to bring stuff over he got
caught um it says here with 43 grams of
heroin
that's trafficking and he was trapping
it through the land border of malaysia
and singapore
oh that's something he was arrested
tried and sentenced to death a year
later under the misuse of drugs act
who's representing his ass they don't
get no representation up there i don't
know how that justice system works but
they did do an assessment by the
psychiatrist like i was saying and they
found out he has total intellectual
disability
um somehow he was exploited by the
traffickers to carry this and uh who's
the [ __ ] judge on this case
the grim reaper they just have such a
low tolerance like when i went to
malaysia there was throw that's the rule
right yeah did you see that there's a
sign at the airport at the terminal when
you fly into malaysia and it's like you
know those like diagrams of someone
crossing well this is not a crossing
it's someone with a gun and it says uh
drugs punishable by death malaysia don't
play and it's like an on-site thing you
go to jail for like [ __ ] spitting gum
out yeah wow
and then next to a sign that has durian
and a no yeah yeah we'll shoot you if
you have durian bro don't you bring that
no durian so uh he's the only reason
this guy's not dead now
is because he caught covid and they had
to delay his execution wait wait
yeah i'm not going to question that but
the variables are funny a lot of laws
they don't plan them together so they're
kind of funny yeah like it's like we
can't kill him yet he's got covid yeah
we're not gonna touch him didn't that
george carlin have a joke about that
where like back then when they did
lethal injection they still have to go
like wait sterilize the needle let me
still like put alcohol so he doesn't get
an affection yeah but it's like you're
gonna get the death penalty like lethal
injection
we could take we could skip this yeah
that is yeah you can skip it
you could dip it in dookie in there
but what if it neutralizes the injection
oh it's like oh you got dookie on it
he's gonna live a thousand years uh he's
invincible now yeah so uh branson's
whole angle about it is that um
he thinks that
singapore carrying through his
executions can affect their
world reputation which is probably
something people like i think so i mean
just hearing this news i was like that's
[ __ ] y'all are dumb yeah like
i mean yeah zero tolerance i get it but
if there's ever like an exception this
is the exception listen to this like um
uh branson nlp it's pretty funny he goes
this is quote he goes it's also worth
remembering the main countries that
still have the death penalty china north
korea saudi arabia and iran
they're not the best bedfellows for
singapore a sophisticated country to be
in the same bed with mm-hmm but
singapore is like no don't worry about
the death penalty
well we do but it's state by state yeah
whereas these are just whole countries
where they it's punishable
we get thrown a technicality into like
america
you ever hear about how um
political
corruption
like
dudes and so if you get caught for
political corruption you get kicked off
of an airplane with no parachute in
singapore do what that's a real
[ __ ] boop yeah i heard they're like
president will do [ __ ] like that yeah
that's kind of tight but that makes
sense right because your
corruption can damage the lives of so
many [ __ ] people you're supposed to
serve the people yeah you're supposed to
yeah so that kind of makes sense or like
i don't know sometimes these draconian
laws i'm like get them bows right yeah
yeah but what about when like i i always
i always be like joking around be like
singapore like the [ __ ] wakanda of
asia like it is amazing it's beautiful
out there [ __ ] makes sense in in certain
ways but you just got to be willing to
accept the way that they run [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean it's like it's like
you spit gum here you're gonna go to
jail you're like what i'll go to jail
but then you look around like this
[ __ ] clean yeah bro not one
piece of trash it's like cause and
effect yeah so it's kind of like i'll
respect it and maybe not even maybe not
even that but like you spit you go to
jail but then there's also a butterfly
effect of things that we can't measure
or see yeah you know like the aftermath
of the aftermath and maybe that's why
some of those rules as much as it
doesn't make sense but it creates a
shockwave of like cleanliness maybe
but then this particular case it just
sounds like
they're so black and white about the
rule that's that's the part
it doesn't it's kind of like where's
your humanity now because it makes sense
if this guy was a drug trafficker he
intentionally did this because he wanted
riches that's completely different from
someone maybe even of normal iq but
maybe they're kidnapping their family
members and they're forced to do this
[ __ ] i think it's you know hard you know
just to play devil's advocate though
maybe it is the heart black and white
that makes that structure
this is like this is it that's like you
know they're like trying to be like
science you know science science is like
this is how it goes science is hey this
happens or b this happens or it's like
um it's like living by idealism
in a macro sense right it's like
thinking like you know americans might
be like oh communism like blah is evil
right but if you really think about like
government idealism communism also works
just like you know totalitarianism works
just like whatever
but as long as it was ideal and it
didn't get corrupt so if if
rules did work for a country right it's
not like singapore is like north korea
or or like iran or whatever not saying
anything about those other countries but
you know what i'm saying
it's like if there's something that
works there's a method to their madness
kind of the method works and you yeah
okay it sucks that i mean look there's a
lot of people american kind of bad one
that that's like was not fair is there a
like um
what's the word
something that they can redeem like you
know that at the end of was that movie
hero the jet li
like at the end everyone's like is the
king gonna kill him is the king gonna
kill him and then it's like yeah the
king has to kill any guy that gets close
to him right but then after they kill
them they erected a giant statue of him
to show how honorable and badass yeah
like he chose to be a martyr because you
had to follow the rules like i know that
i'm gonna give this king spoiler alert
i'm gonna give this king even though
this movie came out 20 years ago i got
to give this king a chance you know what
i mean but that means i'm gonna die can
we just do it and not do it like say we
did it but don't do it oh and then just
secretly let them go that'd be pretty
fine go put the [ __ ] home yeah yeah get
the [ __ ] out he's like nah i'm kicking
it i'm a chair i'm here where i live now
this place is great
one thing i didn't know is that um
vietnam and china execute more people
each year than the rest of the world
combined
vietnam and china yeah china what's up
y'all no that's crazy for vietnam
because china population it's like
execute more than the rest of the world
i'm like okay well popular shirt vietnam
that's crazy god damn i like vietnam too
shout out to vietnam i love being um
yeah that was great and maybe while in
the [ __ ] out in vietnam i forgot how
someone said it's we're still communists
i was like oh this shit's still
communist oh it's still communist i
remember like you know you can't go over
that say saigon you know what i mean you
can't say yeah so cheating but they
party like capitalists let me tell you
that oh yeah they do they love business
like capitalists
vietnam's popping
my way
[Music]